let's go next to
uh let's go to nick from long island
nick welcome
hey david um so
my question is is um
do you think that
so we had primaries last night we had
john fetterman win the pennsylvania
primary
and um
it's looking like conservative democrat
kurt schrader is going to lose his
primary to a more left-leaning candidate
i was wondering because i've heard many
on the left say that progressive
candidates have a better chance of
winning the general election
do you agree with that or do you think
that more moderate candidates have
better chances of winning there's no one
answer for that so for example
in west virginia
if a more progressive democrat manages
to successfully primary joe manchin
that progressive democrat almost
certainly loses the election in west
virginia and we get a republican senator
in a place like pennsylvania i think a
more progressive democrat
is far more likely to do well in the
general so there's no one answer what in
order to say
who is likely to do better you first
have to answer the question well who's
in the electorate are we talking about
nationally are we talking about a
particular congressional district or a
state does that make sense
yeah um well doesn't it like depend on
what policies are popular in the state
we're talking about that's right so so
to say
are progressives likely to do better
the question is well who are the voters
and what do they want
yeah
um
so it's not like it's not like a black
and white thing no not at all not at all
there are there are there are seats
where
a centrist democrat
is as left as would be able to win
there are other seats like for example
aoc's district aoc replaced a longtime
incumbent she she's well to his left
because the electorate lined up with her
views does you know what i'm saying
yeah but that's that's like a safe seat
that's a safe democratic seat i'm
talking about like in mainly swing uh
swing districts well it depends on the
specifics of the district is what i'm
saying yeah um all right um yeah and i
wanted to point that out because i heard
uh
from dave wasserman on twitter saying
that the political report will change
oregon's fifth district to a toss-up
race if
kurt schrader loses his primary to a
more i forgot the
person's name but yeah okay
all right um
all right thank you okay thank you very
much i appreciate the call yeah not one
answer that's a it's a great question
it's a complicated question as well
one of our sponsors is magic spoon the
only breakfast cereal that tastes
exactly like your favorite sugary
childhood cereals but with zero sugar
only four net carbs and 14 grams of
protein so if you're just generally
trying to keep your sugar intake
relatively low like me or if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto
you can enjoy the sweet nostalgic snack
without the sugar in flavors like cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cookies and
cream maple waffle blueberry cinnamon
they've just added honey nut to their
permanent collection i love magic spoon
our whole team does and they've been
supporting the show for years how about
this if you try magic spoon and you
don't think it's amazing like we do
they'll give you your money back because
magic spoon stands behind their product
because it's that good you really can't
tell it apart from the classic cereals
build your own custom variety pack
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is in the description